yes you can look through a dictionary
read through a dictionary it's kind of
fun but my experience is we don't retain
much hi there steve kaufman here today
to talk about dictionaries and language
learning
if you enjoy my videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications
if you follow me on a podcast service
which is a good thing to do if you're
learning english because you can then
study the lessons on link but do leave a
comment i do appreciate it so
dictionaries i am a sucker for buying
books and buying books on things that
are of interest to me
such as history but such as language so
i have bought a lot of dictionaries
way back when i was at school or when i
was learning french or learning chinese
we needed dictionaries we needed and i
got chinese dictionaries this isn't and
i've got many many more i just don't
know where they are right now
so starting with chinese lots of
dictionaries and that's kind of the only
choice we had then
there were there were no online texts
with online dictionaries the dictionary
the chinese dictionary had the big
disadvantage
and to some extent it shares it with
other dictionaries
that it's difficult to look words up
it's time consuming
uh even a sort of a
dictionary that's in the latin alphabet
or in an alphabet where you know the
order of the letters
and therefore you can look things up
based on
that alphabet that's easier when i first
started learning chinese we either had
to know the stroke
the number of strokes in the character 7
8 9 10 11 12 13. and then go look for
that character you know in that section
of the dictionary and if we counted the
strokes wrong
which as a beginner you're likely to do
then you never found it or it took
forever or they wanted you to figure out
the radical the component and then
characters would be organized in the
dictionary based on these components
uh
that again could be
a little difficult
but what is common to
whether you're looking up chinese
characters in a dictionary or looking up
words based on the alphabet
er the problem is that very soon after
you close the dictionary you have
forgotten the meaning
now i should point out that chinese
dictionaries now tend to rely on pinyin
in other words the phonetic script the
latin alphabet based phonetic script
so that you can more easily look things
up but still the problem remains that
once you close the dictionary very
quickly you're going to forget what you
looked up
therefore
a few things become important when it
comes to dictionaries number one
you have to have a purpose for looking a
word up so typically i look a word up
now
if i'm reading or list reading a
particular you know piece of content and
i want to know what that word means so i
look it up
i get it hopefully i haven't forgotten
it by the time i get back to the text
that i'm reading
that's where online dictionaries are so
good because you get the meaning right
away before you forget the meaning
[Music]
so a purpose and i remember as a as a
child playing scrabble with my with my
father or with my brother or my mother
we would look words up in a dictionary
to see if that word was legal in
scrabble
so there's a specific purpose i didn't
even bother with the meaning i might
have glanced at the meaning but i wanted
to confirm that that was a legal word so
there's a purpose so you need to have a
purpose for looking things up
i'll get into later this idea of kind of
viewing words in a dictionary as a means
of learning words which i'm not a big
fan of
uh so you have a purpose the second
thing is it should be as
easy and effective as possible so
when i use a dictionary online or even
before that you know a
traditional dictionary
i want it to come to my language i don't
use monolingual in other words target
language to target language dictionaries
unless i'm very advanced in the language
because i don't want to find a meaning
for that word or a definition which
contains a lot more words that i don't
know okay and i have bought a lot of
dictionaries over time i should show you
these so i show you a couple of chinese
dictionaries here
uh
korean learners korean english
handbook of korean vocabulary again
dictionary vocabulary it's all part of
the same thing
uh
when i and for every language that i
study i get these dictionaries and i
never look at them
frequency dictionary i thought wow if i
can learn the most you know frequent
words that's going to help me in fact it
doesn't because the most frequent words
show up a lot anyway you don't need to
find them in a dictionary ordered you
know by order frequency
so
money spent to satisfy an itch but
didn't really amount to very much
i have farsi phrase book which i don't
look at very much
um you know i bought an arabic english
bilingual dictionary full of pictures
okay haven't really used that very much
there's this 15-minute arabic learn in
just 12 weeks so 12 weeks you don't know
much i can assure you and it's more or
less the same pictures and words in
arabic
yeah whatever spanish english for in
fact the beginning of link was when i
was reading books in spanish and there
were so many words i didn't know on
every page 10 or so
and so i was thumbing through the
dictionary and then in the end i figured
that was not very efficient because i
would forget them or i would list them
all to look up later on and forget them
so that was my spanish english
dictionary i've even bought a number of
dictionaries where i go from one
language that i'm learning into another
language say check to to russian to kind
of see
how where they're similar or different
as you thumb through this slopnic
there are some aha moments but mostly
it's not that effective i don't retain
much and i don't do that much anymore
so getting back then to this idea of the
dictionary and how to make it useful
yes you can look through a dictionary
read through a dictionary it's kind of
fun but my experience is we don't retain
much
or put it this way and i should add
actually a dictionary is just a
collection of words with meaning
i prefer
bilingual so from the target language to
a language that i know very very well
but it can be a dictionary of medical
terms it could be a dictionary of
agricultural terms it can be
simply a vocabulary list at the end of a
chapter in a book it's the same idea
it's a list of words with meaning
and so it's part of this whole
language learning process
so
i think we should kind of
separate and now of course dictionaries
have become online
and there are sort of
flashcard systems and anki and there's a
whole variety of things that have been
built around this idea of acquiring
vocabulary or helping us acquire
vocabulary from our basic reading and
listening activities
but the basic way we learn vocabulary is
through those listening and reading book
activities so that the dictionary or
other vocabulary learning
assists
are simply our minor
systems or resources that help us learn
the vocabulary which we learn primarily
from our listening and reading
so
i do use these uh resources i use online
dictionaries obviously uh at link for
every language there's an option of
three or four or five online
dictionaries that we can use with link
some of them
for certain languages offer you
conjugating
conjugation tables for the word that
you're looking up
uh some of them offer you know help you
with uh writing chinese characters
uh so there's any number of other
resources that are bunched with these
dictionaries
and so that makes them even more useful
as resources uh in terms of review
activities as i've said before i prefer
these matching pairs i've said that any
kind of
review activity should deal with a small
number
of words or phrases you should review
them soon after seeing them in an actual
context and the activity itself should
be as easy as possible to do so that's
why typically i will go through a text
in persian one sentence at a time review
six or seven terms using matching pairs
which is the easiest thing to do
and i do them right away easy and not
too many and so that is kind of my
approach to using these vocabulary lists
as a way to acquire more vocabulary
i really don't spend a lot of time
reading the dictionary however it's
possible to simulate
reading the dictionary the advantage of
reading a dictionary if it's organized
alphabetically is that you can see words
that have the same prefix and that can
sometimes help you connect one word to
another
and we can do that at link i can simply
organize my a vocabulary list i say the
overall vocabulary list or vocabulary
list of words that i'm close to knowing
which is my status three words or from a
particular lesson and i can organize
them by
in alphabetical order so i can see
related words
i think everyone has to sort of design
their own approach to using dictionaries
and vocabulary review activities to help
them
you know to help accelerate the process
of acquiring words and phrases i should
add again that link you can say phrases
that's also very important
uh but by and large if you review these
like i mentioned that i had a somewhere
here a persian phrase book
when you review phrases or words it
helps if they are already familiar to
you
so that the first time you
encounter a word in a dictionary it's to
deal with a specific need what does it
mean in this context but thereafter when
you are reviewing them i find that the
more familiar you are with these
starting to get a handle of these
of the meaning of these words the more
likely you're going to benefit from the
vocabulary review activities including
reading a dictionary if you know many of
the words in this specific dictionary
chances are reviewing it is going to
help you know really
confirm your understanding of these
words
uh but if you encounter a word for the
first time in addiction or you're you're
not very likely to remember it and
you're certainly not going to have a
good sense of the scope of meaning of
that word so just a bit of a ramble on
the role of dictionaries i'd be
interested in hearing your views on the
subject and i'll leave you with
videos that i've done on the subject of
vocabulary and dictionary in the past
thank you for listening bye for now